swampland tall massive trees throughout  the swamp provide new movement  opportunities for agile resourceful  pilots as well as intermittent cover in  tighten to tighten combat  run off combat takes place at multiple  elevations between the upper passages  the main deck and the low line drainage  canals sometimes across long side lines  requiring pilots to develop a strong  understanding of this industrial  battleground  war games characterized by long  transparent wall running paths and a  confined Central Corridor this  simulation places a premium on each  pilots ability to discover new ways to  use these strategic routes against their  foes  by Xbox one get titanfall